[Music]
operant conditioning is based on the
idea that we can increase or decrease a
certain behavior by adding a consequence
for example if a dog poops on a carpet
we can either provide reinforcement so
the dog does it again or punishments of
the dog stops both reinforcement and
Punishment can either be positive or
negative which means we have four
possible ways to teach this dog a lesson
we can draw the four options in a table
if reinforcement is positive we add
something pleasant like a cookie to
increase the likelihood of a behavior if
reinforcement is negative we still want
to increase the desired behavior this
time by removing something unpleasant
like the leash if punishment is positive
we add an unpleasant response to
decrease behavior when punishment is
negative we also want to decrease
behavior now by removing something
pleasant like the comfy carpet if we
stop any sort of manipulation the
conditioned behavior will eventually
disappear again
this is called extinction operant
conditioning was first studied by Edward
L Thorndike and later made famous by the
work of BF Skinner Skinner believed that
organisms are doing what they do
naturally until they accidentally
encounter a stimulus that creates
conditioning which results in a change
in behavior to test this he placed a rat
inside an operant conditioning chamber
which later became known as the Skinner
box among other things inside the box
was a lever that would release food when
pressed conditioning happens in a
three-term contingency today known as
the ABCs of behavior a e stands for
antecedent the rat accidentally hits the
lever that triggers the release of food
B stands for behavior and refers to the
response the rat keeps pressing the
lever C stands for consequence food
keeps coming out
the strength of the response to the
conditioning depends on the schedule of
reinforcement if there is always food
after pressing the rat behaves
predictably if the food is released
randomly the rat behaves erratically
like an addict skinner born in 1904 was
a professor of psychology and subscribed
to behaviorism he argued that you can
only study behavior that is visible and
anything happening only within the mind
is either a misconception or irrelevant
to science
he thought freewill was an illusion
because behavior is either random or a
reaction to the environment his work
became the foundation for behavioral
therapy military drills and animal
training you can try this classroom
exercise on positive reinforcement one
individual must exit the room now decide
on a task which that individual will
complete such as finding a particular
book then choose an honorable way of
reinforcing that tasks such as clapping
your hands invite the person to come
back into the room and let them try and
complete the task but don't give any
instructions every time they are on the
right track in regards to completing the
task clap your hands louder if they move
away from performing the task reduce
your applause or stop it entirely once
the person understands what they are
supposed to do let them explain the task
did they get it right
sprouts videos are published under the
Creative Commons license that means our
videos are free and anyone can download
edit and play them for personal use and
public schools governments and nonprofit
organizations can also use them for
training online courses or designing new
curriculums
to help us stay independent and support
our work you can join our patrons and
contribute just visit patreon.com slash
sprouts even one dollar can make a
difference if you have deep insights
into academic topics and want to help us
explain complicated ideas and simple
language please contact us at sprouts
schools comm
you